just kind of like poke like a little
hole on the side or something and then
you can oh man oh boy
huh then not just happen oh I see I just
smell the soup hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans coming at you from mr. Bing in the
East Village where I'm joined by the
multi-talented Chris woo yeah he's a
singer
he's an actor he's a model he has a song
called deserve with Travis Scott out now
but long before he made it as an
international pop sensation Chris but
time between the East and the West
coming of age in British Columbia and in
China which is why we're here at mr.
Bing a home for Chinese style street
food right here in Manhattan and today
we're rolling out some of Chris's
favorite meals from such one hot sauce
to Shanghai soup dumplings
we'll be feasting on dishes from four
distinct regions in China but before we
start chris is somebody who's spent a
lot of time in China and now spends a
lot of time touring the States
what do you see is the biggest
differences between the Chinese food
that you experience in those cities and
the more traditional dishes that you
have from back home sometimes when
you're out here you expect the food to
be not as good if you're looking for
like a beer additional dish to be not
good with what you will get you know
obviously in China but even out of my
surprise the view in New York or LA or
San Fran like you said you get really
good Chinese food really really really
good time really matches up it matches
up for sure and sometimes even a little
better because the quality that they
were using like say for example meat or
something like that could even be better
obviously cooking is so vast in China
there are so many different regions does
the food vary that much from place to
place it varies quite a lot to be honest
all the stuff like I'm north they like a
little more heavy kind of like the taste
is more like strong like if you say like
Guangzhou Hong Kong they have like it's
lighter they like to drink but they like
super LA so every every meal that will
always have like a soup on the side and
then obviously you have to try yes where
where all the spices were from I was
born in Guangzhou I love spicy food
there they really can't eat spicy foods
two is too spicy for them I Chris I
could sit around and chat all day but
I'm a little bit hungry it's dinnertime
yup you hungry oh yeah let's start
rolling in some plates yeah all right so
the first stop on our tour today is in
Shanghai and we're gonna start with soup
dumplings and when you think about the
soup dumpling there you go classic but
we have not only this but also a very
special dumpling from drunken dumpling
they're kind of famous for this have you
ever seen a dumpling this big before Wow
no do they make them this big in China I
don't think so
not that I know to man so this extra
large soup dumpling it's packed with
crab scallops shrimp and pork and the
broth is made from a combination of
chicken pork and vegetables should we
try it we should try it higher let's do
it I can't wait
wow there's a lot of meat it's like a
what so soup dumplings it's something
that Americans are notorious for
screwing up what do people get wrong
about the soup dumpling no just eat it
right away and the super just spill all
over the place right really hot too so
usually what you do with these guys is
obvious this is way too busy you have a
straw guys we do is usually just take it
put it in your spoon kind of like poke
like a little hole on a sigh or
something and then you can oh man oh boy
huh then not just happen oh boy see I
just smell the soup that's not that's
not what I want to do it that's not how
you do what you do it you would just
kind of kind of sit like with your mouth
and there you go yeah
right just like that you're doing better
than me uh-huh just get that out get
that out and then you can use
where would you get something like this
in China is it a street food but one of
the best soup dumplings where would I go
probably Shanghai but this is a very
famous dish I mean you can probably get
anywhere now in China but if you want
that very um very legit original taste I
would say Shanghai a lot of people think
that this is the theme something right
this because it kind of looks like those
um like Hong Kong bones they like mean
something but yeah you actually and a
lot of restaurants I believe in Hong
Kong or Guangzhou if you order if you
try wear this they won't really have it
where we what we say in the very
beginning is very different for every
every area and they have pride in their
food too and that's why we're going from
region to region all right next up we
have a situation
and hot sauce from Han Dynasty the beef
is stir-fried with cabbage garlic and
celery and a citron chili oil hot sauce
Han Dynasty serves it's dishes I'm a
spice scale from one to ten this
particular dish that we're about to have
clocks in at about a seven can you
describe the difference between a
Szechuan peppercorn and then like a
spicy chicken wing is it different and
if so how the spice is different the
sauce it uses very different so insist I
get this spice and also like a little
numbness if you know what I mean like on
your tongue like it's a little different
and I think what you would expect out
here will just be less it won't be that
spicy well you can sit around is that
real deal the pepper that they use is
something different completely different
it's from the area and and that is like
the most spicy pepper you can find
really yeah and you go there have you
ever just like lit yourself up on one oh
man no no you don't want to do that you
don't want to be eating that because a
lot of peppers you can just kind of eat
it you know it's all good people like
eating it but those are the ones that
you don't want to touch yeah listen no
one knows that better than me
haha let's let's try it let's get in
there yeah
[Music]
not that spicy bright more five more for
ya I say so this is like I got 4.5 Hey
it is getting hot up there you go hard
crank it here we are in Sichuan right
how would this dish be different in
China would it be spicier how'd it be
different maybe spicier yeah
first thing they'll be spicier the soup
immediate just been looking at it you'll
know that is the soup is gonna be really
red Superman this is like kind of like
not as breslow orange like kind of you
know you can tell this is being then
torn down a little more approachable
yeah exactly but the ones you get in in
China oh man they're red like just just
spicy for sure just basically a warning
for you yeah and I think maybe less
vegetables too the only thing you will
see is the meat and then the red peppers
yeah yeah and so you know you're getting
that that that's spicy like you know the
real deal exactly all right up next we
have lobster kanji from Gondo which I
know you is a hometown hero dish uh-huh
what do you remember about this meal
growing up Oh growing up this is my
mom's favorite and she made me drink
this every day almost I swear like I
wasn't really a big fancy food but I
mean you can't really say no to this I
mean have you ever tried this before
this will be my first time and for the
people out there it's a porridge of
boiled rice and water that's often
served with things like fish shrimp
chicken and eggs I feel like every
culture they have that go-to dish that's
kind of a catch-all it's a little
comfort food it's a little when you're
sick yeah and this seems to be checking
those boxes yeah for sure when you're in
Guangzhou in Hong Kong in Guangzhou for
breakfast almost um everyone what kind
of started the day with some type of
kanji this is very smooth and it's very
good for your system it keeps you warm
and keeps you just give you a good
energy to start a date walk with so
filling up the tank with some congee you
know never go wrong with a congee so
this region it's known for Cantonese
food
how is Cantonese food differ how does it
separate itself from other Chinese
when you go to Guangzhou or send Jen or
Hong Kong the temperatures very hot
there it's kind of like they don't
really have like like a very cold
winters but the summer is super long so
people like to keep themselves like
hydrated so they drink a lot of soup you
have congee and all the stuff a lighter
just so you don't get dehydrated like
not that much salty food not that much
spicy food for that reason all right so
we're bringing things home here with the
gem ping as I understand it this is like
a CREP light dish from Beijing that's
become a popular breakfast item all over
China the crepe is made out of mung bean
rice and wheat flour it's topped with
eggs sesame seeds scallions chili paste
cilantro crunchy wontons what's special
about it to you it's almost like a
Chinese burger or something it's very
easy to eat but you know fashion humans
kind of eat it like you know on the road
or any for my bed and it just stays
really good it's really good
trust me try out
let me tell you when this would hit 3
a.m. how big a deal is Street food in
China huge there's so many I mean this
is the obviously one of the famous one
that you get so many and like I said
again different areas different type of
food snacks Street food in Beijing you
have a tall car or something very famous
it's like intestines but like like like
pork and it but it's very good and then
you got the barbecue like Barbie but I
am that did that they'll come on the
spire all kinds of stuff I mean if you
if you ever go to China you with that me
want to try out the the street foods III
was actually um I'm just like randomly
came of this video I just seem to help
how to make this it's actually quite
hard it's not easy no it's a real skill
it's in here you know they don't have
like the the plates out and it's like
there's a real art there's a real
craftsmanship yeah there's nothing
because I thought these were pretty easy
like you just kind of wrap it like that
not it was my bed gotta put like the
eggs on top and kind of like make sure
everything even you know if you want to
learn how hard this is to make will take
it back there will make a bang let's do
it let's do it
[Music]
so we had like a 20-second tutorial and
yeah now we're just going at it alright
I guess first things first we do the
batter right and then I'll start
spreading little wrist action I recall
I'm kind of a natural with the wrist
action and then I remember you pop this
egg yeah right - in it BAM Oh oh boy and
now I flip it oh nice it's tough it's
not as easy as it looks the flip got it
[Music]
duck is down sauce crunchy wontons egg
and then I feel like you make it into a
little pocket how do you do it like this
maybe don't ask me I don't have a nice
this is gonna be my remix on the Bing
kind of go like that kind of go like
that
and then BAM okay this is my take this
is my take on a Bing I'm kind of just
following your lead which is not a good
lead to follow here we have our bings I
kind of stumbled at the dismount put it
into the plate and the whole thing fell
apart
yours Chris that looks very good yeah
thank you as a restaurant quality right
there they should have that right into a
seamless order the song deserved with
Travis Scott it's out now make sure you
check it out and then of course refers
to me feast I'm Sean Evans
until next time Internet
[Music]
[Music]